it's Aquila and I'm with Comedy Central
at South by Southwest trying to talk to
some people about what South by is about
how's the festival treating you crazy I
got shot you know Austin's an amazing
comedy town what's your favorite thing
about South by Southwest that people
play the guitar you can smell the
patchouli you will just get in the zone
so he's like patchouli are you talking
about weed yeah there's a lot all right
that was a cool way of saying it is
everything bigger in Texas my dreams are
bigger this Wi-Fi is fast and my bumble
is loading black or pinto beans pinto
racists their beams of color you know
like fava beans do people tell you all
the time that you look like if Martin
Luther King's dream was realized one day
that black people and white people and
Mexican people can come together in
Austin and be weird do you remember the
Alamo is that when pie has ice cream on
it it was one of the first gay bars a
lot of people don't know that tinder is
basically my yeah it's my Waterloo it
was cute